Щиро вітаємо вас це програма У фокусі
Європи від телекомпанії Deutsche Welle
майже 8 мільйонів людей покинули Україну
з початку російської збройної агресії
Багато з них травмовані цим однак
невелику частину біженців Це здається
влаштовує
на Лазурному узбережжі Франції
ці кадри багатого життя українських
мільярдерів та олігархів далеко від
війни опублікувала незалежно інтернет
газета Українська правда
Багато з них живуть уздовж розкішно
французькою середземноморського
узбережжя у величезних вілах зокрема на
півострові сажа капфера
Джоні рукою
так знаходиться великий центр
розподільної для людей які були змушені
покинути Україну іноді це призводить до
абсурдних ситуацій коли травмовані
біженці прогуляючись можуть дивитися із
Набережної Ніцца на розкішний світ своїх
багатих земляків на яких за словами
Українки Ірини бурдель ще й лежить
частково відповідальність за війну в
їхній країні
Вони протестують проти російського
ракетного терору українські діти жінки
люди похилого віку що втекли від війни
на південь Франції ними опікується
волонтерка Ірина бурдель
Українка живе тут уже давно
війна досі триває зима буде дуже-дуже
важкою
тут їхати сюди
Путін терорист допомагає також і Оксана
Басова вихователька дитсадка втекла з
Києва після російського вторгнення її
Чоловік працює інженером відновлює там
зруйновані російські маркетами системи
електропостачання
син Оксани Олексій знає російські атаки
загрожують його татові У той час як мама
бореться за виживання тут але на
Лазурному узбережжі є й інші біженці з
України Вони живуть на розкішному
острові капфера біля ніцци
і вони охоче хизуються своїм багатством
мільйонери мільярдери олігархи багатьох
із них вважають багаторічними
прихильниками Путіна в Україні і
джерелом корупції
тепер вони гості казино монте-карло
їх влітку поіменно ідентифікувало
незалежно український інтернет-видання
Українська Правда воно називає їх
батальйон Монако
деякі з них були депутатами від
проросійської партії яку Київ улітку
заборонив
ці люди не лише були частиною
корумпованої еліти вони також несуть
відповідальність за війну в Україні
оскільки закликали Росію прийти в
Україну
для нас вони справді є відповідальними
за цю катастрофу
планується нормально сам скажу катастроф
залишилися сьогодні контактів з
українськими мільярдерами Ірина бурдель
та Оксана Басова немає
місто Ніцца безоплатно передало
французько-українському культурному
товариству цю крамницю
замість культури допомога біженцям
психологічна підтримка дітей травмованих
війною
поруч лежать складені приватні пожертви
більшу частину приміщення товариство
використовує для догляду за дітьми та
вивчення з ними французької мови на
вулиці у черзі за продуктами стоять мами
та бабусі які потребують допомоги раз на
тиждень туди пускають усіх і ретельно
реєструють це приватні пожертви та харчі
які фінансує управління соціального
захисту населення
кілька банок сердин
сардини Так
але чи вистачить цього на цілий тиждень
[музика]
Зате біженці які живуть у розкоші
катаються на човнах або роз'їжджають на
дорогих машинах
у березні український антикорупційний
блогер опублікував цю фотографію
йдеться про 28 мільйонів доларів США та
1 і 3 мільйона євро
фотографія зроблена угорською митницею
під час в'їзду дружини одного народного
депутата України до ЄС
чому митниця на південному заході
України не помітила контрабанду готівки
і досі невідомо Але можливо серед
українських біженців мова йде про дещо
більше ніж гроші
влітку до капферал неквапливому темпі
бігав народний депутат Ігор Абрамович
він вийшов із лояльної до Росії
парламентської групи ще до її заборони
разом із іншими він заснував з-за
кордону нову депутатську групу чи
відновлюється тут старі зв'язки у
сонячному екзелі коментувати це
українським ЗМІ народний депутат не
бажає
у Києві мінусові температури тут дуже
уважно стежать за новими мережами старих
друзів Росії
[музика]
Олександр саліженко спеціалізується на
депутатах українського парламенту та
їхніх контактах
але за даними українські правда це
Сергій
візьмікін колишній Начальник
Департаменту захисту економіки
нацполіції
разом з Ігорем абрамовичем
така тенденція в них Київський слідчий
направили до європейських поліцейських
організацій повідомлення про розшук двох
і скількох десятків підозрюваних ми
зв'язуємось із речницею дбр України за
допомогою відеозв'язку
перевіряється чи законне громадяни про
яких іде мова у журналістському
розслідуванні перетнули кордон і чи
причетні вони до легалізації майна яке
отримали як підозрюють слідчі державного
бюро розслідувань швидше за все
злочинним шляхом Але знову ж таки
грунтуючись на попередньому досвіді
перспективи цієї справи і як традиції в
мене не великі
для України які перебувають у центрі для
біженців у Ніцці цього буде недостатньо
ну чи пізно цих людей запитають що вони
робили і їм доведеться відповідати
вони сподіваються що друзі Росії з
України опиняться за ґратами вони
сподіваються на кінець вірогідної мережі
на капфера так званого батальйону Монако
бізнес на платному сексі мабуть не
процвітає жодні іншій країні Європи так
як в Іспанії на думку багатьох іспанців
причини цієї занадто слабке
законодавство держава втручається лише
тоді коли можна довести експлуатацію або
насильство тепер уряд хоче покласти
цьому край І взагалі заборонити
проституцію не всі секс працівниці та
секс працівники з цим згодні багато хто
боїться насильно опинитися в
нелегальному становищі однак вони
сусільве сподівається на заборону зі
свого довгого і болючого досвіду життя
секс індустрії
цей промисловий район у Мадриді нагадує
їй про погані часи
[музика]
Ванесса Сільва сама була повією
бразилійка мала мало малолітню доньку та
переживала фінансові труднощі Так вона і
потрапила до рук торговців людьми які
вивезли її до Іспанії
[музика]
коли тебе вербують хто розписують Усе в
яскравих фарбах
але коли ти сюди приїжджаєш все зовсім
інакше
у мене забрали паспорт і я раптом
опинилася зовсім одна на іншому краю
світу
[музика]
10 років поспіль вона продавала своє
тіло тут в Іспанії де попит на секс за
гроші найвищий у Європі
у єдиній країні ЄС яка досі не
врегулювала Конституцію на законодавчому
рівні
і я цей європейський Тайланд вхідні
ворота для мігранток які щодня стають
жертвами торгівлі людьми і уряди про це
знають але нічого не роблять
але зараз іспанський уряд планує
прийняти закон суворі покарання для
сутенерів і штрафи для клієнтів так Він
хоче зупинити торгівлю людьми та
сексуальну експлуатацію
нарешті крок у правильному напрямку
кажуть дієва Перес і Тереза медуеніо
Вони працюють у благодійній організації
і постійно відвідують повій на вулицях
Мадрида
закон хоче дати жінкам вихід із
проституції але Він потребує
вдосконалення він повинен забезпечити
отримання цими жінками легального
статусу перебування
щоб жертви торгівлі людьми та
сексуальної експлуатації мали
перспективу і більше прав
легше було повідомляти про своїх
експлуататорів
вона проти закону бленд драки побоюються
за свої засоби до існування іспанка
секс-працівниця і як вона каже повністю
самостійно вона зустрічається з
клієнтами Вдома Або в готелі але якщо її
клієнтам будуть загрожувати штрафи вона
перенесе свій бізнес у підпілля
Конституція нікуди не зникне про це
слідча численні приклади з інших країн
які запровадили такі закони
проституція там все що є натомість
якість життя повій вкрай погіршилась
таким значно ускладнюють життя
[музика]
проституцію не можна криміналізувати нам
потрібні закони які визнають нашу роботу
щоб ми теж могли отримати право на
допомогу по безробіттю на пенсію
набагато чого іншого
Сільва відвідує офіс гуманітарної
організації яка опікується повіями
держава повинна все-таки дбати про те
щоб жінки які перебувають у скрутному
становищі не потрапляли в проституцію
взагалі а чоловіки не купували секс
послуги
так не повинно бути щоб жінку яка не має
їжі змушували лягати в ліжко з чоловіком
огидним брудним хворим жорстоким
нашпигованим наркотиками це не
сексуальна Свобода
[музика]
Ванесса Сільва коли була повією пережила
жахливі речі їй вдалося з цього
вибратись але навіть у 50 років Вона не
відчуває себе застрахованою від нового
соціального падіння
для темношкірої жінки та ще й у моєму
віці імовірність не знайти роботу дуже
висока а тому існує ризик знову
потрапити у проституцію
саме тому вона хоче бачити жорсткі
закони проти проституції торгівлі людьми
та сексуальної експлуатації і не лише в
Іспанії а й у всій Європі
[музика]
багато людей напевно жахаються коли
бачать як зросли їхні витрати на
опалення
ціни на енергоносії в Європі просто
вибухнули тому дехто одягає товстий
светр і просто менший опалює своє житло
їдуть у відпустку наприклад на кілька
місяців до Туреччини Можливо навіть на
всю зиму дешеві пропозиції приваблюють
поїхати на південь все більше туристів
8 година ранку на пляжі турецького
Приморського курорту Сіде
люди займають лежаки рушниками цим
ранковим видом спорту займаються
передусім туристи з Німеччини Великої
Британії та Нідерландів
з того часу на ногах також і Юсуф Костюк
поки я можу прогодувати свою сім'ю я не
переживаю і слава Богу що я можу
забезпечити сім'ю так життя нелегке але
я люблю свою роботу
готель в Сіде розрахований на Приблизно
1000 гостей до цього часу взимку їх
завжди було значно менше зараз це має
змінитися ось цюрк старанно працює тут
всього за 330 євро на місяць німецькі
гості почали приїжджати сюди вже з 1
листопада місяць відпочинку для однієї
людини тут обійдеться не менш ніж у
тисячу євро включно з перельотом та
повним забезпеченням При цьому вони
економлять на споживанні електроенергії
та газу подружжя дукслер з Австрії та
подружжя херасталь з Німеччини тут на
довготривалий період сьогодні у програмі
їхнього відпочинку кулінарний курс ті
хто перебуває тут понад два тижні хочуть
відволіктись від сонячних Ван біля
басейну і керівництво готелю це Добре
відомо
усі четверо пенсіонери коли влітку їм
сказали що ціни на енергоносії вдома
будуть зашкалювати дешевий відпочинок у
Туреччині восени одразу ж став бажаною
альтернативою
як не як ми тут вже 8 тижнів і 8 тижнів
економ на опаленні та на електроенергії
тож це безумовно окупилося
Ми навіть думає про те що взимку
виїжджати за кордон на довший період
позаяк нам подобається цей клімат ця
погода а також економія коштів
А можна заощадити чималі гроші
враховуючи високі ціни на енергоносії
залишатися вдома було б не набагато
дешевше каже подружжя а якість життя на
турецькій рів'єрі однозначно краще
Деніс угюр керівник туристичної фірми
Він вважає що кількість зимових туристів
у цьому сезоні зросте більш ніж удвічі
до 900 тисяч гостей з Німеччини причина
також і в тому що збільшилася цільова
група раніше це були переважно
пенсіонери та люди які вже не працювали
сьогодні ж на додачу також багато фірм і
співробітників фірм які дозволяють своїм
працівникам виконувати роботу за
кордоном
22 дні відпочинку в Сіде менше ніж за
600 євро профспілки в Анталії вважає що
це зрештою може призвести лише до
банкрутства
турфірми намагаються продавати Туреччину
дешево але це неправильно так вони
шкодять самі собі це можна побачити на
прикладі готелів які банкрутують
змінюють власників або вимушену
продаються ми знаємо готелі де
адміністрації більше не могла платити за
оренду і просто зникала наприкінці
сезону
тим часом Настав вечір Садівник готелю
змушений працювати понаднормово але це
вже другорядне каже він
до нас співробітників наші гості у
пріоритеті
бо якщо вони не приїдуть у нас просто не
буде роботи
А робота Є пріоритетом для багатьох
Турків через економічну кризу та
інфляцію Україні
коли в Польщі взимку опалюють будинки з
димарів іде диму понад 3 мільйони
польських будинків досі опалюють вугілля
і навіть воно зараз стало дефіцитним і
дорогим через ембарго на імпорт Росії
на це байдуже разом із колегою він
вчасно перевів свій багатоквартирний
будинок на відновлюванні джерела енергії
від чого виграють усі мешканці старого
панельного будинку у місті щитно адже
електрика і тепло з Цієї зими вже не
коштують їм жодного злотого
панельний будинок у Польщі з унікальним
дизайном зверху донизу покритий
сонячними батареями
тут зупиняється в автомобілі
фотографують будинок Він досить
унікальний я б рекомендував це також
Своїм знайомим
мешканці спокійно чекають на зиму
зростання цін на енергоносії для них не
проблема Я люблю підійматися сюди на
гору І насолоджуватись видом на
генератор Він виробляє не лише
електроенергію а й гроші
щитно невелика містечко на півдні
мазерій тут мало що відбувається Але є
одна пам'ятка із 1970-х років панельний
будинок номер 12 по вулиці сланський Він
привертає увагу балкони сонячними
панелями тут встановили лише у вересні
збігнив храбковський голова
організованого колективу мешканців
робить свій звичний обхід Вітаю Добрий
день привітало Я хотіла ще й подивитися
як там нашу установка чи працює вона
належним чином у мене все в порядку
подряпин немає все зроблено акуратно але
я вже замерзла добре ховайся всередину
а зовнішній вигляд може бути справою
смаку але зрештою Це не має значення
оскільки будинок практично повністю
енергетично самодостатній єдиний такий у
Польщі
колишній вугільний підвал тепер є офісом
двох-візіонерів так називають мешканці
керівників свого колективу при цьому
поштовхом для трансформації енергетики
став просто брак грошей
це була трагедія енергетичні компанії
чинили на нас фінансовий тиск
Повірте я просив їх хоча б дати нам
розстрочку з мене сміялися А у вас нема
грошей це стало для мене поштовху
Це був 2014 рік Невдовзі після того як у
підвалів встановили тепловий насос на
духу фотоелектричну систему усе
фінансувалось за рахунок кредитів від
держави та власних внесків мешканців так
вдалось заощадити 80% витрат на
енергоносії А зекономлені кошти пішли на
погашення кредитів і навіть на
фінансування нових проектів зокрема для
балконів цього року які використовують
для нагрівання води для мешканців на
сланській 12 настають світлі часи
Добре зараз коли ціни на енергоносії
стінку зростають Вони й далі радісно
опалюють будинок
днями є розмовляла зі своєю сусідкою
Вона запитала мене Ну що ви вже отримали
підвищення що за підвищення спитала я ну
збільшення комунальних витрат ні
відповіла Я у нас їх вже давно немає
22 градуси є для станіслави стандартної
температури але іноді буває тепліше
тепер до неї частіше приїжджають друзі
та рідні Мій син каже ой у вас завжди
так тепло опалення просто можна
ввімкнути навіть улітку коли дні стають
трохи прохолоднішими я вже пропонувала
йому щоб ми помінялися і я думаю що він
зрештою це зробить
А балконами так всі заздрять вони значно
більші застарі тільки повітря не завжди
хороше особливо зараз коли знову
розпочинається опалювальний сезон
будинок на сланській 12 це лише
Острівець з відновлювальною енергетики в
безмежному морі система опалення що
працюють на викопному паливі тоді у 2014
році збіднів на вид запитував сусідні
будинки чи не хочуть вони приєднатися
але з них лише сміялись і називали
мрійниками сьогодні вони про це шкодують
Ну у нас постійні підвищення щось нове
кожні кілька місяців і ми не маємо на це
ніякого впливу у нас просто немає
адміністрації яка була б так само
віддана колективу мешканців як У
сусідньому будинку те що збігнів та його
заступник настільки віддані справі
можливо пов'язано ще із тим що вони самі
живуть у цьому будинку із часом суто
фінансова мотивація на початку
перетворилась на розуміння захисту
клімату та довкілля їхній
багатоквартирний будинок заоща майже 70
тонн СО2 на рік якщо ви перенесемо це на
інші подібні багатоквартирні будинки то
це 25 тисяч у всій Польщі лишень Уявіть
собі скільки коштів Можна було б
заощадити скільки чистою енергією
скільки чистого повітря може було б
виробити щороку від самого помирають 40
тисяч людей
збіг не в храбковський сподівається що
люди тут у його місті
на ремеслет це він навіть розглядає
можливість наступного року балотуватися
на посаду мера
Прибережний ландшафт Уельсу вражає уяву
а вид на море захоплює дух я теж Вільям
схоче захистити цю красу своєї
британської батьківщини до цього
перукарка вдається до особливих засобів
із волоссям вона переробляє зрізане
волосся свій клієнтів своєму салоні
маленькому ворійському містечку хавер
Форвард миття стрижка та сушка феном
важливі тут не лише для гарного
зовнішнього вигляду
[музика]
кладемо волосся навколо твого обличчя
так воно виглядатиме живим а потім
проведемо ще й курс лікування
Адель Вільямс любить потурати клієнтам у
своєму салоні в уельсі для перукарки її
робота завжди була чимось більшим ніж
просто стригти волосся
для людей волосся дуже важливе і це не
має нічого спільного з марнославством
твоє волосся це велика частина твоєї
особистості якщо твоє волосся погано
почувається То погано почуваєшся також і
тих самим
для того щоб її клієнти завжди
почувались добре Вона не поспішає але за
допомогою волосся 27-річна жінка хоче
також рятувати довкілля кожен тут у
салоні робить у це свій внесок
Я завжди намагалась переробляти речі але
довгий час відчувала що може робити щось
більше своїми діями мені тепер вдається
перетворити відходи на щось корисне для
світу
сьогодні ця клієнтка фарбує Волосся зі
світлого кольору грошей потім щойновими
та й підстрижене волосся потрапляє у
підсобне приміщення салону і
обробляється на цьому валяльному
пристрої щоб фільтрувати потім із моря
нафту
я розділяю волосся на тонкий пасма щоб У
підсумку це виглядало як сітка
потім усе це кілька разів пропускають
Через машину Поки воно не стане товщиною
приблизно сантиметр і тоді це вже
килимок із волосся
а Дель Вільямс виросла на заході Уельсу
прямо на узбережжі А вона любить пляж і
море біля свого рідного міста
хаверфортвес
якщо тут колись станеться розлив нафти
можна буде використати її килимки
адже волосся особливо добре вбирає жир і
сиру нафту килимки з волосся поглинають
у 9 разів більше олії ніж становить їхня
власна вага їх вже використовують у США
екологічна альтернатива звичайним
пластиковим килимкам кажуть екологічні
організації
приблизно 900 тисяч перукарень у США що
тиждень зрізають до кілограма волосся
своїх клієнтів
і ми всі миємо волосся шампунем бо
знаємо що в ньому збирається олія тому
ми об'єдналися із перукарями які роблять
із цього волосся килимки що поглинають
нафту
для того щоб підготувати для цього і
Європу а Делі Вільямс співпрацює з
американською недержавною організацією
вона налаштована оптимістично адже
інтерес проявляє зараз навіть нафтова
промисловість зараз килимки з волосся
випробовують деякі нафтові компанії Ми
сподіваємось що незабаром вони замовлять
їх у великих кількостях і замінять ними
пластикові килимки
рожева зачіска Майже готова і клієнтка
вже задоволена і не лише новим стилем
піти до перукаря і водночас пожартувати
своє волосся щоб позбутися нафтових плям
це чудово Я так рада тебе бачити лоці Я
теж рада тебе бачити Дуже дякую волосся
каже молода перукарка може набагато
більше ніж просто мати гарний вигляд я
Дель хоче доводити Це далі
[музика]
Може мені все-таки відростити волосся це
була програма У фокусі Європи і
телекомпанії Deutsche Welle Дякуємо і до
зустрічі наступного тижня українською
мовою озвучено центром медіа ініціатив
переклад Володимира та Олесі Швед
режисер Павло Тимченко так читали Олена
потоцька Юрій Лисенко та Олесь гоян Київ
2022 рік